[Music]  perched on the cliff sides of the Mesa  Verde plateau exists the remnants of  prehistoric Pueblo Indian settlements  for nearly 700 years the ancestral  Pueblo and culture flourished in what is  modern-day Southwest Colorado from the  6th through 12th centuries elaborate  villages were constructed on the Mesa  tops canyons and cliffs of the 4,400  archaeological sites that have been  identified in the area one of the more  famous is cliff palace on chapin mesa  [Music]  some 24 Native American tribes consider  the site to be their ancestral home  constructed of sandstone and mud mortar  that multi-story cliff palace has 150  rooms Mesa Verde National Park was the  first archaeological site in the world  to be protected by law in 1906 even  before the establishment of the National  Park System  [Music]